le trophée du meilleur chroniqueur
[Musique]
le bris en matthieu delormeau
j'aime plaza hanouna dechavanne ou un
petit peu aussi ce que j'ai connu
patrick les années 90 au théâtre tristan
bernard
et c'est là qu'on a commencé à être pote
échos du coup on a ça pèse sk non je
pars et non pas bien vite devoir faire
marquer l'année non c'est vrai comment
il s'appelle je ne m'explique pas
pourquoi je crée ça c'est les gens ces
phénomènes de bigoudis
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dithyrambique gilles verdez voir ça sur
tf1 même s'ils ont beaucoup de talent
gilles legrand blindtest césar vie quand
ça doit s'arrêter
je pense que le rand boccolini c'est la
télé du passé tout est bidonné vous
dites c'est normal cette ville de l'est
partout il est bon repos castaldi
le business et le business mais le
téléspectateur lui qui est habitué à ces
jeux en fait il est privé des missions
on a payé mon avis a pas du tout
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
éloquent benjamin castaldi
quand sa campagne
[Applaudissements]
c'est dégueulasse aura besoin que l'on
fasse des caisses jazz plus devant qu'un
ouragan il se pourrait il se serait que
crime de crime parfait
[Applaudissements]
tu vas arrêter de faire ça y est le pt
et non ça
le facétieux maxime gainey
oui les maxima la meilleure boulangerie
de france ça marche pas terrible
bataille rangée palette de nuances a
plutôt bien marché
rendez compte de ce qui est montré
aujourd'hui les enfants sont lobotomisés
par blessé quitte à n'être qu'ils
arrêtent un automobiliste
vous savez je ne suis pas le dernier
pour faire la nouba l'indétrônable jean
luc lemoine
j'accepte on peut vous insultez qu'on
est malade malade petit connard le
préciser que vous n'êtes jamais trompé
jusqu'à présent pas aussi avec toi quand
même vous c'est quoi votre mois de
l'année car benjamin le respect bien
vous jean-luc c'est quoi le monde je
suis comme elbit oman pour moi
actuellement
tu es le meilleur sniper de la
télévision et je pense que c'est pour ça
que tout le monde en coulisses tu
appelles mst
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'imprévisible jean michel maire
vous posez une question toute simple
cadeau ou fait aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui j'ai dormi oui donc c'était
suite possible ce crime de là les deux
chez richard chez les chiottes
j'aime beaucoup de johnny mais comme en
otage jusqu'à 8h au poids merde alors
[Musique]
les gants bernard montiel
il peut y avoir contre la montre
bernard montiel qui est en survêtement
qui va rentrer peut-être d'amendements
[Applaudissements]
alors est ce que sait faire la moue
réjouir c'est pas pareil
voici 7 à fin de carrière
quand on vient d'enterrer quelqu'un il
ya des pôles et six ans des gaz qui s'en
va donc j'imagine quand benjamin
castaldi va c'est l'attenté
[Musique]
ils sont sept ans vous tient bon motard
et qu'il a fait excuse moi tu es sur tt
entre jean-luc eux n'hésitent plus jean
michel lui était bon jean michel lucenay
benjamin lors du défi qui votent
ah oui c'est vrai je suis merci merci
merci
allez bye bye les succès comme je vais
dire je vais dire jean michel jean
michel maghe halfway pour l'ensemble de
son oeuvre jean-michel merde
matthieu delormeau jean-luc jean-luc le
pur sang ah ouais là pour cent des
talons mais là non métallos italiens qui
l'avaient arrêté en vietnamien la plus
petite kelly peep-toe arrêter quoi
[Rires]
ça arrive avec tarbes à excuse moi mais
quand benji je vais te parler de toi
dans un sens mais parce que comme on
sait que vous êtes très très proches
voilà c'est votre meilleure amie dans
les gymnastes objectif qu'a très bien on
m'a très bien elle peut mais le talent
s'il devient snipers
benji à moi j'ai benthiff je trouve que
tu as fait encore une année fort
blizzard ce n'est mieux que l'année
dernière ça c'est infime
j'étudie c'est la dame et benjamin je
vous dire c'est devenu à un poteau
incroyable c'est vraiment voilà je vous
dis hein
mais même dans la vie et benjamin je
voulais te dire non mais t'as est un
sens de l'autodérision et ce qui est
incroyable
franchement on n'arrête pas de charlie
on n'arrête pas enfin on se dit tout
haut ce ban trucs et benjamin il fait
tout jamais jamais il a resigné affaire
à mettre un déguisement à faire un truc
à remplacer le vendredi je l'appelle il
est un amour de paix voilà je sais que
c'est vraiment très fort et est un
talent incroyable tu dis tout ce que tu
penses tu es vraiment je te dit aussi
voilà quand je fais des missions le
matin jeux mais benjamin tout de suite
tu es celui qui en a fait le plus cette
année je suis tellement heureux que tu
nous a rejoint et j'espère vraiment que
tu partiras plus qu on continuera
ensemble pendant des années dans les
prochaines décennies
bah oui mais non mais même y'a pas que
l'année prochaine tu sais je vais te
dire tu sais tu vois loin et je vais
dire je pense qu'à ton 6e mariage suis
travers encore
jean-michel vert alors jean michel tu as
fait un début de saison pas ouf cette
année de merde
ouais franchement c'est vrai je te dis
la vérité mettez toujours toi tu rtt un
des buts adultes un diesel non ça c'est
j'aime pas du tout cette expression dieu
merci mais c'est qu'au début
et toi t'es pas dedans c'est parce que
tu as tu reviens de vacances tu as plein
de meuf tu es dans des délires sur voie
des doses de l'été et pas bien et
clairement toi quand tu es partie
difficile de tarek ben oui
ah non non franchement après deuxième
partie de saison après janvier
tu as été incroyablement marie janvier
web à la fois janvier juin incroyable
mais quand j'ai l'incroyable un coin
après je me considère un petit peu et
même si on a une différence d'âge dans
l'autre sens un peu comme ton papa c'est
vrai c'est à dire que c'est chaud
obligés de gérer jean-michel dans les
missions en dehors de l'émission le
week-end dans ses problèmes avec la
maréchaussée
non merci dans ses problèmes avec les
meufs dans ses problèmes ça ne me
dérange pas si tu pourra toujours
compter sur moi je sais tu le sais
nantais problème avec des meilleurs mais
maintenant oui ou des trucs comme ça je
serai toujours là tu le sais mon chef je
suis comme eux vraiment je te jure je me
considère comme ton papa voilà et je
t'aime fort est encore fait une année
exceptionnelle et je sais que tout aussi
franchement on s'arrêtera ensemble
j'espère maxime maxime guennoun 1 chez
daunat maxime gagne alors maxime je vais
te dire tu as fait un début d'année très
bon et puis ensuite un tas a eu un petit
bout de femme et ses deux frères de sang
michel ferry est un excellent camarade
non mais t'es un excellent camarade
franchement est toujours de bonne humeur
j'adore être avec toi avant l'émission
tu me fais rire
après t'as juste un seul défaut c'est
que il faudrait que tu sois un peu plus
percutant
c'est à dire que tu es un peu plus je
sais que tu es et encore et encore un
peu peur de te fâcher avec des gens tu
as peur de dire du mal de dos d'un tel
ou de tel propos du yotel animateurs t
je vais tenir on est juste là pour juger
la télé c'est pas parce qu'on dit du mal
ou qu'on critique une émission de nous
c'est qu'on ne l'aiment pas voilà donc
il faut que tu te lâche un petit peu et
très bon effet un vrai style vous fait
beaucoup rire j'espère que cet été tu
vas pécho parce que ça va peut-être
déclencheur c'est pas trop loin je te le
dis mais vraiment a fait belle saison tu
fais partie de la famille et affirmé ton
encore plus et je vois que tu le fait de
plus en plus et n'hésite pas à répondre
aux autres aussi quantitatif surtout à
matthieu delormeau jules toujours un des
piliers après voilà tu es celui sur qui
je m'appuie le plus quand j'ai besoin
d'eux quand j'ai une image ou personnes
selon laquelle personne veut réagir
je sais que toi tu peux réagir surtout
voilà j'ai juste un petit truc a demandé
est ce que tu es toujours sincère dans
ses jugements
parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya plein de
téléspectateurs qui se demande moi aussi
parfois c'est vrai que tu es on se dit à
chaque fois tu dis que l'émission va
s'arrêter que c'est un accident
industriel que rien et tout et tout est
pourri que tf1 va s'effondrer est ce que
tu es toujours mesuré nommé est ce que
tu es toujours français est ce que tu
penses vraiment ce que tu portes
est ce que tu dit aucun mot que j'ai
prononcé ici n'a pas été sincère
ah ouais rien j'ai tout tout et c'est ce
que je ressens lac sans filtre parce que
c'est ce qu'on s'était dit quand on
s'était rencontrés je parle comme si
j'étais par l'antenne c'est grave non
sans filtre sincèrement avec emportement
et passion parce que l'émission
passionne je suis passionnée et j'y
jouais te dire au site et voilà je sais
que je t'aime très traitement je sais je
sais qu'un de mes plus fidèles
je peux compter sur toi so lu ment voilà
je peux toujours condé soit tu sais que
tu peux compter sur moi je sais aussi
voilà et j'espère que même ton émission
sur ses news
je sais pas j'ai pas demandé faire c'est
vrai tu me dis ça comme quand il dit ça
sur son audience d'hier tu sais comme
quand arrive chez what et pyatt à rome
elle te demande si elle a rendu le
contrôle de maths la prof nous et une
veine on en fait à l'ap a rendu parce
que
hier il ya eu un ado cédric dis la
vérité je ne sais pas je le dirai c'est
non c'est drôle c'est que dans les
audiences de toutes les émissions du paf
sauf la sienne - amateurs d'avenir
matthieu delormeau matthieu delormeau
tu sais tu devais pas venir cette année
c'est vrai qu'au départ c'était pas
prévu puisque tu devais arrêter
l'an dernier on s'est vus autour d'un
petit-déjeuner m'a coûté 26 11
mais vrai vous pouvez les rembourser ça
m'arrangerait voilà pas 26 pour l'argent
enfin je t'expliquerai causé pas mal
sinon c'est très bien car on a compris
et bien tu te casses toi d'accompli 81
euros venu mathieu je trouve que sous
les 2 on a passé une année
exceptionnelle tu me fais rire est une
des personnes vraiment même je te lis de
toutes les personnes que j'ai tu crois
que tu es un des mecs qui me fait le
plus rire autant à l'antenne corentin et
homme qui rit c'est bon aussi avec la
dtn bête de scène pour moitié aux stars
non mais je te le dis voilà je te dit
c'est vraiment une star et tu vois là je
te je te regarde parfois dans l'émission
dès que la décla caméra s'allume
tu étais là tu te transformes je le dis
tu es vraiment rien ne vient jamais seul
il est bien évident à talons
exceptionnel quelque chose que tu gâches
le pense pas et toi aussi je trouve
vraiment a fait une saison mais là cette
année à la tête était vraiment a été
testée jatta jamais aussi bons
[Applaudissements]
après après je demande juste un truc
arrête de croire tu peu me chaut
parce que ça n'arrivera jamais ouais nan
mais je t'explique c'est mort de che
morts ça veut dire mais on peut rester
même huit ans sur une île déserte
ensemble je préfère aller chez des noix
de coco ananas doit gagner 11 ans à
garos mais parce que tu sais pourquoi
ouais parce que tu es un ami 1 ça ne
mange pas à me bat mais je te jure était
tellement un ami voilà c'est ça passe
pas ça peut pas à te le dis ok mais en
tout cas pathétiques ces tunnels bernard
montiel bernard toi tu t'es tu t'es dash
est beaucoup plus que l'an dernier réd
dernière tf1 un petit essai tu avais dit
du mal de deux ou trois personnes
tu t'es pris d'état né dans les dîners
privés dont tu dis jure je vais me
calmer
parce que c'est vrai que j'ai pris 2,3
hélas cette année et à 10 comme on dit
nico mais c'est vrai mais s'était dit
j'y vais j'y vais à fond
en y allant à fond gris devenu on tape
dans le monde relate aussi je te dis
était devenu un titulaire indiscutable
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que tu es là ce
soir tu était quelqu'un que j'aimais
beaucoup avant de travailler avec toi et
tu m'as toujours défendu vraiment je me
rappelle que tu sois la radio sur les
autres émissions partout et je sais que
tu es vraiment un fidèle et que je peux
compter sur toi sache que toi aussi tu
peux compter sur moi et bernard et
maintenant tu fais partie de la famille
j'espère que tu vas rester dans la
famille en pleine forme pascal vraiment
fort c'est vraiment quelqu'un que j'aime
énormément et je me sens bien quand et
là voilà j'ai besoin de toi dans
l'émission et je trouve que tu veux je
pense tu vas faire encore une saison
encore meilleure l'an prochain à jouer
que le lien oui parce que je crois que
je vais balancer un peu plus encore je
vais arriver à la retraite bientôt donc
mais tu as raison
bajaj auto commente
lionel tu entendu je suis plus tout
jeune non plus et il est bon d septembre
ya que moi qui se boit parce que c'est
forcément merci oil
vous êtes très bon à partir de janvier
bonjour lui alors jean-luc encore une
fois cette année c'est vrai que on se
dit chaque année on se dit ouais j'en
lui peut-être les quatre tiers à sare et
man bien peut-être il va des vannes
russes qu'il y aura plus de matière mais
je trouvais déjà que les quatre tiers
puis franchement je pense que c'est une
des meilleures années et 4/3
je trouve que c'est chaque fois j'espère
que je les attends hier que je suis chez
moi
le mercredi après midi en train de
regarder la télé je sais pas trop bureau
et je me dis dans ce soir il y avait
quatre tirs de jean-luc les attentes un
talent d'écriture incroyable en ce night
franchement qui fait partie pour moi des
trois meilleurs en france depuis des
années et a pas été détrônés tu es
toujours au top
tu restes classe tu peux dire tout ce
que tu veux en plus tu es mon pote on se
comprend en un clin d'oeil
t pour moi la tétée un des plus
importants voilà je te le dis ici et
tais toi pour moi quand j'étais à côté
de moi je suis rassurée celui était
toujours au top ça veut dire déjà me
voilà il n'ya jamais une émission je
trouve en dessous où les quatre tiers
sont moins bien ou toi je te trouve -
bientôt de la table voilà je trouve que
tu as fait une année encore formidable
et se dit arrives à te renouveler
paris va trouver un autre ton tu arrives
à trouver de nouvelles vannes et je vais
dire t'as ya plein de vannes que tu as
fait et dans ma tête je me dis [ __ ] il
les a fait avant moi ce nom mais
vraiment bravo bonjour lesbos merci mont
joli on va voir
le chroniqueur de l'année qui a été des
escros nique en avait parlé
brillant maintenant de l'engrenage vous
jure je m'y attendais pas du tout
faire de toi
[Applaudissements]
c'est vrai mais la patte vania c'est pas
truqué devrait mieux parce que je
percevais des gens peu comme ça qu'est
bon allez j'en avais je vais profiter ça
dérange pas j'aime pas du tout prévu
coup de bol j'ai toujours un petit mais
un petit texte sur moi au cas où un truc
m'arrive mais je vais te dire non mais
j'ai profité qui reste invitée du fait
qu'ils réseau national à sa place qu'est
ce qui alors je suis rien ça dure 24
minutes mais c'est une feuille a4
on ne sait rien vraiment ça va aller
très très vite mal un week-end à mercier
évidemment tous les fans tous les deux
leurs moeurs voilà qui sont en français
qui ont voté pour moi ça m'a beaucoup
touché je suis ému et je voulais
profiter de cette petite 30 secondes qui
me restent comme aux oscars de la
musique pas pour remercier les fans à
l'étranger si vous permettez du coup
dire un petit mot anglais et bien sûr
dire un mot à tous les fans du maghreb
tous les deux leurs moeurs du maghreb
qui me suivent depuis le début tunisie
algérie maroc et tout ça je vous aime
simplement dit je vous ai manqué à
narbonne
[Rires]
pas convaincu le mérite mathieu goubel
aura manqué par hook et